where they click here and you're not
gonna believe what happens next
generation we've thrown up with the
internet and know every trick in the
book over the years we've built up an
impenetrable detector except it
doesn't work on us you know it we know
it
everyone knows it so then why hasn't
anyone figure this out yet
we are the hustle and we're proving that
the only way to penetrate one's
detector is well not to
each morning we sent out a daily email
using our bold the irreverent and
authentic voice to cut through the sea
of nonsense explain current events to
young professionals throughout the world
our editorial team speaks to our
audience in the way they understand and
love and delivers that content where our
audience lives each morning their email
so far things are going really well
since launching the daily email last
April we've grown to 200,000 fiercely
loyal subscribers from all over the
world with an industry crushing open
rate of 40% our users are young
ambitious extremely intelligent in the
future shot-callers of the world now on
to the important stuff word of mouth has
been our biggest growth channel we have
over a thousand brain ambassadors who
have helped spread the word and we've
also had thousands of people attend our
events which has helped create community
and buzz advertising event sponsorships
and ticket sales
we've been profitable since August of
2016 and then recently raised a round of
funding so we can grow faster and expand
the community we've raised money from
some extremely successful entrepreneurs
and media founders you can see the
entire list below email is one of the
most intimate ways a brand can
communicate with their users it scales
easily with a small editorial team the
advertising rates are significantly
higher and most importantly we want to
play games and use clickbait to get
people to click on our articles and
their social feeds we're on a mission to
capture the young professionals market
as fast as possible our next goal is Ted
a million subscribers within the year
while maintaining our industry crushing
engagement AFER's once there we plan on
expanding the community and offering
different products
services so want to join our pirate ship
[Music]